the Lord of an alternate World regrets
creating humans and sends several
calamities to kill them but there's
someone who risks himself to protect the
next savior of humanity while everyone
is busy in their mortal lives an
archangel named Michael falls on Earth
to carry out a special task he pulls out
his wings and sews the wounds Left
Behind then he breaks into a weapon
storage and steals bags full of guns the
police catch him red-handed and Order
him to surrender but all of a sudden one
of the police officers changes his
appearance his eyes turn dull and teeth
get pointed
he stares at Michael and asks why he is
going against the orders in response
Michael declares that from now on he
will follow his own mind he shoots the
officer and takes the police car to
travel to his destination meanwhile in
Mojave Desert a young girl named Charlie
is pregnant while her boyfriend has
refused to take the responsibility of
the child she works as a waitress in a
restaurant named Paradise Falls Diner
luckily she has a strong friendship with
Jeep the son of the restaurant owner Bob
Charlie is planning to give her child up
for ad ad option as she can't afford to
be a mother Jeep feels sorry for her and
offers to share the responsibility of
the child Charlie calls Jeep an angel
but she doesn't allow him to carry the
weight of others
mistakes the next morning a married
couple Howard and Sandra stop at the
restaurant along with their Rebel
daughter Audrey their car engine has
shut down and they will be stuck here
for a few hours another customer named
Kyle reaches the restaurant looking for
a phone booth as there's no service on
his cell phone Charlie suggests s that
he can ask Bob to let him use the
landline they get inside the restaurant
and Bob notices that Charlie is smoking
again he advises her to quit but she
reminds Bob that he is a smoker too but
Bob refuses to accept that and says that
the lighter he keeps is just a memory of
his wife Sandra interrupts them to ask
how long Jeep will take to fix their car
Bob gets out to check on him and takes
this as a chance to discuss an important
matter he doesn't want Jeep to follow
Charlie like a puppy and take the the
responsibility for her Reckless acts
Jeep says he can't help himself he has
been having weird dreams for days which
makes him think that he must look after
Charlie and her child hearing this Bob
admits that he also used to have dreams
and took them seriously his wife stopped
him from building a restaurant in the
middle of nowhere but Bob thought it
would be successful as he won't be
having any competition but now Bob has
realized that he was wrong he doesn't
want his son to make the same mistake
and regret his whole life Jeep doesn't
say anything in response and Bob gets
back inside he notices that the
television has stopped working and
climbs a chair to fix it meanwhile Kyle
uses the landline to call his son but
doesn't get the chance to talk to him
and the call drops the radio isn't
working either everyone starts making
different assumptions there can be an
earthquake or a terrorist attack that
has disrupted the communication system
Bob doesn't take this matter seriously
and tell Sandra that her car is going to
be fixed soon so her family can get back
on their way after a while an old lady
enters the restaurant and orders a steak
she seems really friendly and greets
everyone Sandra asks the old lady if she
knows why there's no phone service but
the old lady says there's nothing to
worry as it will be over soon when
Charlie brings the food the old lady
asks about the baby and unexpectedly
says that the baby's going to burn
Charlie leaves in anger but Sandra asks
why she said that the old lady starts to
use abusive language so Howard walks to
her to make her apologies but all of a
sudden the old lady uses her sharp teeth
to bite Howard's neck he is severely
injured while the old lady is climbing
the walls like a monster she attacks Bob
and his gun Falls in front of Jeep but
the kind boy can't bring himself to
shoot someone luckily Kyle has a gun too
and he shoots the monster to death
Howard is bleeding continuously so the
restaurant Chef Percy Takes Howard and
his family towards the city in Kyle's
vehicle but just after a few miles they
witness a swarm of insects heading their
way the insects enter the car and make
them return to the restaurant it's been
an hour since that old lady died but her
her body is still warm it may not be
safe to keep her inside so they wrap her
in a plastic back and hide her outside
Bob notices a police car heading their
way and feels relieved it's Michael the
angel Bob points the gun at him and asks
Michael to show his teeth they seem
normal but Bob is still not satisfied
because he doesn't seem like a policeman
Michael doesn't have time for this and
snatches the gun in a smooth motion
Percy begs him not to kill anyone but
Michael isn't interested in doing that
anyway he tells them that there are more
like the old lady and they are coming
this way he returns the gun to Bob and
gets more guns from the car to give one
to each of them they are going to need
them soon they all get inside and lock
the door as soon as the night sets in
they hear an ice cream truck coming the
men get on the roof and Michael briefly
tells them how to use the guns the ice
cream truck stops in front of the
restaurant and a man steps out he seems
normal at first but then his arms and
legs grow longer than usual and he turns
into a monster Michael shoots him but he
wasn't the last one a huge Lane of cars
head their way and they all have turned
into some demonic creatures Michael
instructs his team to keep shooting he
even uses bombs to destroy the enemy's
Cars one of the monsters breaks through
the window and pulls Howard outside
after a while the monsters leave by
themselves Michael gets down and finally
explains the current situation he says
that the Lord has lost his faith in
humans at first he sent a flood and now
he sent an army of monsters to sweep
away the human race the humans are
possessed to act like this and behind
this is not the demons but Angels who
are ordered to kill humans Michael was
one of them too but he had faith in
humanity he came here to protect Charlie
because her child is the last hope to
save Humanity Charlie can't believe this
she is just a waitress how could her
child be faded to carry out such a noble
task but Michael says it doesn't matter
who she is either the child lives or
mankind dies all the possessed humans
will reach here again to kill the child
their first attack was just testing the
water next one is going to be severe
Percy and Kyle head to the roof to keep
an eye on The Intruders Kyle says that
it's the first time he has used his gun
he only kept it to scare others and
never thought he would actually fire at
someone Percy is recalling his childhood
when he was a kid his father would sit
by his bed every night before he went to
sleep he used to say Percy my son if you
don't wake up tomorrow and today is your
last day would you be proud of what you
have done so far if not then you should
start working on that Percy believes we
should live every day as our last day on
Earth and make a difference Kyle is left
speechless after this conversation and
starts rethinking his life decisions
meanwhile Bob is cooking some food and
offers Sandra to eat if the world is
ending that doesn't mean they should
starve themselves on the other side
Michael and Jeep are preparing for the
attack Michael wants Jeep to understand
his situation he says that he used to be
like a soldier who served his master but
the master lost faith but Michael didn't
Jeep wonders how Michael can still have
faith Jeep himself lost everything he
kept faith in believing in things only
brought trouble hearing this Michael
tells him more about the Lord when the
humans were created Michael started to
have big hopes but then he saw humans
being ungrateful killing each other over
race and greed fighting Wars over dust
and proudly writing their violence in
books but in the midst of all this
Darkness Michael saw a few people who
never give up despite failing again and
again Jeep is one of them he was 15 when
his mother left and his father separated
himself from the rest of the world Jeep
sacrificed 5 years of Youth to help his
dad in his unsuccessful business then
Jeep fell in love with a woman who is
having someone else's child but Jeep
still loves her even after knowing that
she will never love him the same way
people like Jeep are the reason Michael
still has faith in humanity it's time
for the next shift so Michael and Bob
head to the roof to guard the next
morning Sandra is awakened by a familiar
voice she rushes to the door and Peaks
through the window it's Howard he is
tied up and screaming for help Sandra
starts unlocking the door and Percy and
audre try stopping her Sandra doesn't
listen and runs toward Howard who
suddenly explodes like an acid bomb
Percy Shields Sandra and brings her back
inside but he is severely burnt by the
acid and dies Bob blames himself for the
incident as he fell asleep and didn't
keep an eye on the road but Michael
Comforts him and explains that
everything is not under their control
Sandra is tied to a chair so she doesn't
do anything crazy again Audrey is
treating her mother really politely but
Sandra has totally lost her mind she
blames Audrey for all what happened
Sandra believes her life would be better
if Audrey was never born Kyle scolds
Sandra for torturing her poor daughter
and asks Audrey to check the radio she
can hear something and calls everyone to
listen the military has managed to
secure some places from the apocalypse
and one of those places is just an hour
away from the restaurant Audrey and
others want to leave but Michael says
they can't take any risk until the child
is born hearing this Charlie recalls the
time when she got to know she was
pregnant she tells jeep that she never
wanted the child and even went for an
abortion while sitting in the waiting
room she started to have this weird
feeling she felt like she was falling
into the deepest darkest hole imaginable
it was like dying when the doctor called
her she ran away blindly and avoided
thinking about the abortion on the other
hand she knew that she couldn't afford
it and this made her hate the baby Jeep
advises her not to think like that
he believes that she can go through it
Charlie needs to understand everyone
faces hard times and they need Faith to
survive meanwhile Audrey joins Kyle on
the guard she blames herself for her
father's death she has never been a good
daughter but Kyle says that it's not all
her fault he also was a spoiled teenager
because his father only paid attention
when he did something bad but when Kyle
became an adult and got a family he
realized that he can't be bad anymore
one day you have to take respons
responsibility for your Deeds suddenly
the electricity is restored and
surprises everyone Kyle notices a car
coming this way it seems like a normal
guy and his little kid they stop by the
gas station and the man steps out to
fill his car but several other vehicles
are heading this way too Kyle shouts at
the man to get back in the car but
before he can other cars reach there and
the possessed humans kill him the kid
reminds Kyle of his own son and he jumps
down to save him Bob wants to go out to
help Kyle but Michael doesn't let him
open the door otherwise they all will
die Kyle rescues the kid but the
innocent looking kid is also possessed
and attacks Kyle Audrey rushes to help
him but Kyle is already dead Audrey
locks herself in the car but she is
still in danger Charlie tells Michael if
he doesn't save Audrey Charlie will to
keep the child safe Michael gets out to
rescue Audrey he successfully brings her
inside but the possessed kid also sneaks
in he grabs a knife to attack Charlie
the lights turn off again but Jeep and
Michael kill the possessed kid Charlie
starts crying in pain as she is about to
give birth with Audrey and Michael the
child is finally born Audrey shows him
to her mother and Sandra regrets what
she said to Audrey every child is the
most precious one for his parents
hearing the baby's voice the possessed
humans start to retreat none of them can
come near the baby so the Lord is going
to send another Archangel named Gabriel
to kill the child Sandra breaks ties and
grabs the baby she believes if they
throw away the baby they all will be
saved to protect the baby Michael shoots
Sandra however Gabriel has already
arrived Michael gives the child to Jeep
and asks him to wait for the
instructions Jeeps run away along with
Charlie and Audrey while Michael faces
Gabriel and gets killed the injured Bob
Burns his restaurant to kill Gabriel but
the angel survives and goes after the
baby Jeep applies sudden brakes which
causes Gabriel to fall out of the
windshield while the car crashes on the
side Audrey dies on Spot while Jeep and
Charlie take the baby on a nearby Cliff
the instructions have appeared on Jeep's
body and he keeps fighting to protect
the child Gabriel proceeds to kill him
but gets stopped by Michael he has been
reborn as an archangel all this was
Lord's plan to test his angels whether
they will follow orders blindly or keep
faith in what's right Michael has passed
this test and Gabriel failed hearing
this Gabriel returns to the sky Michael
has to go too but Jeep wants to know
when they can meet again in response
Michael tells him to keep Faith the sun
rises and Jeep and Charlie head to the
town to start a new life with the baby
at the end
it's all about keeping faith